bonsoir Jérôme Durin une réaction sur ce
grandchlem entre guillemets la
sonetloire qui est ce soir totalement
acquise au Parti
socialiste je suis pas certain qu'elle
soit totalement acquise au Parti
socialiste en tout cas les électeurs ont
choisi la gauche c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour nos candidats et nos
candidates dans les plaisirs de cette
soirée il y a évidemment le fait d'avoir
réussi ce grand Chelet mais il y a aussi
le fait d'avoir réussi à donner à cette
à deux circonscriptions des des élus
femmes puisque la son n'avait jamais eu
de député femme et là avec Cécile
luntermerer et edit got qui vont faire
le rentrée à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
vraiment un très grand plaisir pour les
socialistes du département alors edit
guot a été élu sous l'étiquette divers
gauche parce qu'on sait qu'elle est